now let's get to our five headlines
okay number one journalists today
journalists today are celebrating
another
journalist who asked the question
it's it's a little bit of scare quote
overlord here overload but uh
basically this it's all bullcrap is what
i'm saying but he asked a question
and is being hailed and celebrated for
uh
this question listen to it here after
three and a half years
you regretted all all the lying you've
done to the american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who has done
you have done uh tensorflow go ahead
so what we have here is what we've seen
for uh
especially during the trump now it's
been this way for for decades really but
especially during the trump era this is
journalism as performance
it's not journalism at all it's just
it's a performance he's he's he's
performing for the camera
what other point would there be to that
question what well you know
you're asking the president united
states a question you're in a press
conference
this is this is supposed to be a service
that you're providing for the people so
that we can get answers and that sort of
thing
kind of answer what kind of answer do
you think you're going to get from that
no what he was hoping for in fact this
was just antagonism uh this was he was
hoping for
some kind of angry response from trump
and then he could mix it up and
uh try to embarrass trump and at the
same time elevate himself of course
that's what this is all about but
uh that's you know i didn't go to
journalism school but
admittedly but i i don't think that's
what journalism is actually supposed to
be number two
david blaine is back the magician
performance artist uh i guess is what we
call him he's got a new stunt planned
big deal hasn't done anything in 10
years okay what has he cooked up for us
now
a decade later he's been working on this
we're told for a decade
what is it he had well what he's going
to do is he's going to hold on to some
balloons
and float really high that's the plan
here's the the preview
[Music]
all right i doesn't strike you as a bit
egotistical to call this stunt the
ascension
but you know the real problem is is that
a guy already did this
remember there was that guy that tied
balloons to his lawn chair and floated
up to
like mars or something i believe if i
remember correctly uh
in fact multiple people have done this
they made a they made a pixar movie
about this
in fact which is based on a true story
so this is this just
i to me this is disappointing ten years
and this is what you come up with
i'm gonna hold a balloon and float
cool i you know i would love to do that
too but i just don't know if it quite is
worth the hype
um number three reading from the daily
wire says
more than 25 percent of young americans
age 18 and 24 have seriously considered
killing themselves during the last month
according to the morbidity and mortality
weekly report released on thursday by
the centers for disease control and
prevention
uh says the chronovirus disease 2019
pandemic has been associated with mental
health challenges related to the
morbidity and mortality caused by the
disease into mitigation activities
including the impact of physical
distancing in state home orders um
symptoms of anxiety disorder and
depressive disorder increased
considerably in the united states during
april or june of 2020 compared with the
same period in 2019.
now this is many of us warned that this
was going to happen
you're not only taking away people's
jobs and livelihood you're isolating
them
um keeping them shut away from contact
with other people
and so of course you're gonna have now
especially for someone who's already
dealing with
depression dealing with uh anxiety
mental illness whatever it is shutting
them away and on top of that
you're also bombarding them every single
day with the with you're going to die
it's a disaster it's the end of the
world type of stuff so it's just
it it's not surprising it's tragic and
horrible it's not surprising they would
have this effect remember
trump brought this up months ago and
again
our truth-seeking truth uh
finding journalists in the media mocked
him for it
and fact-checked him trump brought up
months ago
that this is going to lead to suicide
and depression then we got all the
fact check oh no it isn't they said well
here we are
although i do think we should also note
it because it's important that you know
and this is this is one of the reasons
why
um the
the the lockdowns and the effect on
mental health has been so bad is because
we already live
in a culture that is very depressed
and much more suicidal than at other
points in history
and it's a problem that goes down into
very young ages
so this is this is this is part of a
cultural trend a long-standing cultural
trend
which isn't to downplay but precisely
the opposite to say that this
we've got a a serious problem and even
when we get past the lockdown insanity
they're still going to be this problem
and we could talk about you know
dissecting this and
but but one of the one of the
i think fundamental things feeding it is
that we live in a culture
that is at its core quite empty and
people have
no sense of purpose no sense of any
greater reason for existence
it's a very nihilistic culture and so
that's what
is going to lead in part to this as well
number four brett favre
speaking to the usa today shows us shows
us what courage
truly looks like this is brett favre he
says
um and he was asked about the kneeling
issue he says i know from being in an
nfl
nfl locker room for 20 years regardless
of race background money you grew up
with
we were all brothers it didn't matter
guys got along great
will that be the same with the kneeling
scenario i don't know if one guy chooses
to stand for his cause another guy
chooses to kneel for his cause is one
right and the other wrong
i don't believe so we tend to be fixed
on highs
i don't know what it's like to be black
it's not for me to say what's right and
what's wrong
i don't know we should all be true i
know we should i do know we should all
be treated equal
if you can't do that you shouldn't be in
america there's no right answer other
than that the right answer is
that we all get along it seems like the
more people try
the more damage is done this is you know
yeah
what a courageous answer from bradford
but all these all these athletes are
proving
they may be physically tough but uh when
it comes to moral courage there's a real
deficiency there
your answer is well then there's no
right there's no wrong
here's all i'll say we should all get
along
that's i'll take a stand and say we
should be getting along
great insight from brett favre number
five here's something
that i just found out existed um proving
the old adage that ignorance is bliss
erotic weight gaining is a thing
unfortunately the new york post reports
on the important story of a guy named
brian nicknamed
gaynor bull who has intentionally gained
over 300 pound
pounds he eats ten thousand calories a
day one meal for him is like three combo
meals
five or six sides now has a stomach the
size of a small asteroid and
again all of this is on purpose uh some
kind of
like fetish and he apparently has
legions of fans who watch him eat
and just enjoy gazing upon his
bulbous physique one fan on instagram
for example left a comment saying you
are one perfect inflating huge handsome
bear by the way the words inflating and
handsome
really don't go together but but
here's my point um do i have a point
i think i do the point is that the
internet should be destroyed
uh it is a cancer it is a virus
um and this is this is part of the
problem
this guy brian clearly mentally ill
his fans clearly mentally ill
uh and and mentally ill people have
always existed presumably
fat fetishists have always existed in
some capacity
but now with the internet people like
this are are able to congregate they're
able to form
communities where they encourage each
other in their perversion and their
degeneracy
and that's maybe the worst thing about
the internet there's a lot of
competition for that title but
perhaps the worst thing is what it has
done to the concept of
community because it used to be that
your community
was the neighborhood where you live uh
or or you form a community
as a church or around some other sort of
solid healthy thing real world
thing now a community just becomes a
collection of people who enjoy
the same thing and and often the thing
they enjoy is repulsive and
self-destructive and bizarre
so there's no edification there's no
growth well there is growth just not
not emotional and spiritual growth uh is
what i'm talking about
there's nothing nothing positive to come
of of the community other than this
mutual encouragement to continue being
weirdos
and that's most of the community on the
internet that's really what it is
just a bunch of weirdos getting together
and encouraging each other and telling
each other that they're not really
weirdos
um you know it's it's someone has some
some freaky gross thing they're into
they can just google it
and boom they find a whole collection of
other lunatics just like them
whereas in the past before the internet
you know they would have hidden that
part of themselves in shame
as they should maybe seek counseling for
it either of those options
are better than what we have now um and
because now you can you can
you know it's certainly preferable to or
preferable to going on instagram
and getting your kicks by watching a
morbidly obese man eat a burrito which
is what's
where we are now and and by the way this
cheapening of the idea of community
it doesn't just apply to this fetish
type type of stuff
i mean i think it applies even to you
know people that say they're in a
community because they all like the
movie star wars or something like that
um or you know communities of people
that play video games
there's nothing wrong with playing video
games or liking star wars that's not
really a community though that's just
you enjoy the same thing great
that that shouldn't be a community
because there's no other there's no
shared value system there
um the only shared experience is just
this recreational thing you like doing
uh it's not really what a community is
supposed to be and
we we as humans do need community
but we're finding we are we are
fulfilling that need in these kinds of
communities around
some one little thing that we like even
if it's a perfectly fine thing
rather than fulfilling that need through
a real real life
[Music]
um you know community
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content